Fire Emblem engage is the first major
release of 2023 and we've played the
first eight chapters here are 10 of the
biggest changes coming to Nintendo's
long-running tactical RPG series with
some of my early spoiler-free
Impressions sprinkled in
2019's Fire Emblem 3 houses was a huge
success for Nintendo and I'm sure there
are some fans expecting the school-based
structure from that game to return and
engage while the social Sim aspects are
still intact the school-based mechanics
unique to three houses have been removed
this means you won't be choosing a house
or faction at the beginning of the game
you won't be teaching a class of
students or taking any out to tea and
you won't be managing your schedule week
to week instead Fire Emblem engage
follows a more traditional structure
similar to Fire Emblem Awakening battles
can be selected via the world map and in
between skirmishes you can return to
your home base to purchase new equipment
chat with your units and partake in some
diversions in my experience so far
engage is a lot more linear than Fire
Emblem 3 houses in which you could
choose one of three houses recruit
different students and even make a few
major decisions during this story
everyone who plays engage will likely
recruit the same people and follow the
same route through the story this may
not be a bad thing if the story is
really engaging but those of expecting
three houses Dynamic social progression
will find this to be a little more
straightforward
the iconic Fire Emblem weapon triangle
is back and I couldn't be happier prior
to three houses fire emblems combat used
to revolve around a rock paper scissor
style triangle sword beats ax ax feeds
Lance and land speed sword meanwhile
hand-to-hand Arts beat bows daggers and
tomes if you fight a unit you have a
weapon advantage over it will cause a
break breaking an enemy means they can't
counter-attack the most efficient way to
deal with enemy units is by taking full
advantage of the weapon triangle
okay time
I'm sorry
a small but meaningful change is now you
can control your units directly instead
of drawing out a path for them while
it's still grid based this new approach
offers a little more precision and
flexibility to movement
poison status effects have popped up in
Farmland games over the years but they
work a little differently and engage
instead of doing tick damage at the
beginning or end of each turn now poison
units take more damage than they
normally would from attacks poison can
also be stacked meaning that if you hit
a Target multiple times with a poisoned
weapon you'll do even more damage
weapon durability has been almost
entirely removed from Fire Emblem and
gauge thank God weapons cannot break and
nearly every weapon can be upgraded with
proper materials and gold although
weapons cannot break staves can after a
certain number of uses so you'll need to
keep track of that in the menu
okay before we move on to number six
let's pause for a moment since I've been
talking all about the changes coming to
combat I wanted to talk about my
experience so far I've been playing on
the hard difficulty with classic Mode
turned on and thanks in part to all
these changes combat feels balanced and
satisfying no one unit is overpowered
and every character serves a specific
role so far almost every battle apart
from the first few have required a lot
of forethought and careful planning I'm
really excited to see how this expands
as I progress okay back to the numbers
after each battle you can explore the
battlefield talk to allies collect
resources and adopt pets it's kind of
cool to see these battlefields up close
after each battle and it's adorable you
can just take these little pups home
with you between battles you can return
to the somnia which acts as your home
base there have been things similar to
the somniel and past Fire Emblem games
but engage there are some new activities
you can participate in you can exercise
to give your character a temporary buff
in the next battle you can feed and pet
Sami for some extra Bond fragments
animals you've adopted will gather
resources for you in between battles at
the animal pen you can share a meal with
two other units to increase their bond
which isn't exactly new but this time
you can save the leftovers for battle
you can train in the arena three times
after each battle to get a little extra
XP you can donate to different countries
to increase your reward pools after
skirmishes and finally you can purchase
alternate outfits and accessories for
your units the Cosmetics only affect the
unit's appearance at the sommeal though
and not on the battlefield
at the center of fire emblemen gauge is
the emblem ring mechanic throughout your
journey you will collect emblem rings
that house the spirit of past Fire
Emblem protagonists when a unit equipped
with an emblem ring engages they summon
a classic hero to fight alongside them a
unit armed with an emblem ring typically
enjoys some stat Buffs a new weapon
which can be used while engaged and a
unique skill the period lasts for three
turns and then the engage meter must be
refilled either by attacking getting hit
casting spells or standing on a
designated recovery tile depicted as
blue spaces on the map some of the
emblem Ring characters I've been able to
utilize so far are Marth from Fire
Emblem shadow dragon and Smash Bros
Celica from Gaiden and its remake Echoes
Shadows of Valencia sigurd from
genealogy of the holy war Makaya from
radiant Dawn Roy from the birding blade
and leaf from genealogy of the holy war
and thracia 776 want to know how many of
those games never came to the us the
answer is too damn many anyway just like
your standard units you can also Forge
bonds with your emblem rings by battling
with them equipped and chatting with
them at your home base by improving your
bonds you'll unlock new skills in stat
Buffs which can be purchased with skill
points in the ring chamber along with
emblem Rings you can also Forge Bond
rings using Bond fragments Bond Rings
also feature characters from past Fire
Emblem games but these rings only give
equipped units stat Buffs once you've
unlocked an emblem ring you can purchase
random Bond rings from their respective
game 100 Bond fragments will get you one
Bond ring and 1000 will get you 10 by
collecting duplicate Rings you can meld
them together to forge more powerful
versions of those same Rings thank you
the ring looks amazing fire Bloom engage
adds hundreds of in-game achievements
that can be converted into Bond
fragments once you've completed a few
you can head over to the protagonist's
desk and claim them these achievements
range from deploying specific units
multiple times to Landing a certain
amount of critical hits
anyway those are 10 of the biggest
changes coming to Fire Emblem and Gage
keep in mind that this is based on the
first eight chapters of the game so some
things could change and new mechanics
could be introduced later down the line
stay tuned for the full review in the
coming weeks
now
it's time to engage